Film Courage: We had this comment come in from [Youtube subscriber] Milly
Purpose "How do you know people will
laugh or share and have sort of the same
humor that you have." Todd Berger, Co-Writer of The Happytime Murders Movie: I mean you never
know when people are gonna find funny
what you find funny and you never know
when they're gonna laugh what you laugh
it but sometimes I don't care like to me
I'm just trying to do something that I
think it's funny and I hope with fingers
crossed that other people are gonna find
it to find it funny too and you know
there are certain jobs I'll take where I
try to like if I'm gonna write a kid's
movie I should I think get into the head
of a kid like what would I thought was
funny if I was a kid if I was seven
years old like what I find this funny
but when I write when I'm a unbridle and
I'm writing a comedy and I just want to
write something really funny I just
think about what would I Todd burger
find really funny and and if other
people find it funny great if they don't
well that's on them maybe they need a
better sense of humor you know but you
never know and like you can't I think as
a comedy writer you can't try to get in
the heads of other people and think what
they're gonna think it's funny
you have to just write what you think is
funny and you'll find out later I mean I
read stuff in happy time murders that I
thought was really funny and then we
have a test screening of the movie
people did not think that that joke was
funny I thought it was really funny or
the opposite there'd be something that I
didn't think was very funny then people
thought was hilarious and you're like oh
you never know like you never know what
people are gonna find funny
you just hope you hit more than you miss
and and hope that people are on the same
page with you but really we should all
be just we should all be writing movies
that we want to watch we should be the
target audience every row in the movie
and even if you're writing a kid's movie
you should want to write a movie that
you would want to take your kids to or
if you were a kid you would have wanted
to watch and and yeah so like you should
be your own audience what's wrong that's
a bumper sticker yeah we should all be
our own audience that's probably like a
Netflix slogan we don't know about be
your own audience
thank you for watching interview with
Todd Berger recently we've begun hosting
live events where we bring together the
film courage community if you enjoy
watching this channel we encourage you
to join us this upcoming Tuesday October
23rd we have a class with Pamela J Smith
entitled mythic challenges how writers
can create stories that change the world
we think is going to be fantastic check
out the link below and hopefully we'll
see you there